tsunamis infamously ignore international
boundaries and and so it is that tsunami
science needs to ignore international
boundaries this is not the only one of
its kind don't be surprised if another
one happens
tsunamis are caused by major earthquakes
out to sea these happen in places where
tectonic plates crash together tsunamis
tend to occur at subduction zones and we
can see subduction zones [ __ ] the
pacific ocean we have the Cascadia
subduction zone here middle America
trench down here and of course the Peru
Chile change down here which generated
the largest subduction zone earthquake
ever recorded in 1960 you have a
tectonic plate one of the parts of
Earth's outer shell that moves relative
to another part 1 tectonic plate diving
at a gentle angle under another but the
plates stuck together where the
overriding plate has its leading edge so
that the overriding plates stuck gets
bulged up in between times and then
during the earthquake kicks the seafloor
and that helps to drive a tsunami it's
it warps the seat for when such huge
waves hit beaches they scoop up vast
amounts of sand which is left behind in
layers stretching far inland
the 2004 tsunami was generated offshore
Sumatra and also the andaman and nicobar
islands north of Sumatra it was known
there's an earthquake this big measuring
9.2 on the richter scale and releasing a
huge amount of pent-up energy had not
happened in the Indian Ocean for at
least 200 years now nature publishes the
work of geologists who won covered
massive tsunamis which hit the same
region about seven hundred and fourteen
hundred years ago the wave hit Sumatra
first along with the enamine nicob are
islands the next place it was hit with
Sri Lanka followed by the Maldives and
then East Africa Kenya and even
Madagascar Bryan McAdoo and his
colleagues surveyed the devastated areas
of Sumatra very soon after the tsunami
hit we're about two or three kilometres
and he chaired still dealing with at
least ninety percent of every structure
by a solid meter high above ground wave
which maybe two or three meters above
sea level given a motor so that the
runway because when the frisbee how many
people saw that ron ron ron van de
runway runway something like that
imagine a wall of water coming at you
it's about 10 meters high turns out it's
about 10 meters per second that the wave
comes in Hussain bolt just one 100-meter
dash and the Olympics in just over nine
seconds if you're Usain Bolt you could
maybe outrun this wave but then imagine
the wave comes in for one kilometer
Brian at water and Maria Martin joined a
geological team in Thailand a country
also badly hit in 2004 what they found
their makes them particularly concerned
for the safety of people in their own
very vulnerable part of the pacific
northwest of america today accompanied
by david Hollett from the island county
department of emergency management they
demonstrated for nature just how tsunami
geologists work they hope to confirm
work already done by scientists from
Texas and British Columbia according to
the work that was done here by Harry
Williams and Ian Hutchison throughout
this area and down the road a bit they
mapped a pair of sand layers the first
place they dug quickly reveal the proof
that feels sandy ok the best guess is
this from the year ad 400 and this is
close to the Year AD 700 not as
spectacular as the tie layers but still
something real huh
so what evidence did the geologists find
in Thailand though our Thai colleagues
began soon after the 2004 tsunami with a
survey to map out the areas that had
been covered by the tsunami it must have
been a horrible job for them because
they're going into an area of such
disaster and so much loss of life I
think all of them were geologists
dealing with tsunami for the first time
on this paper the lead author is Quran
Janko from Thailand her colleagues
mantri and took Brian and myself from
the u.s. Yuki sawai from Japan namie
Pendergrass from Australia we go out to
these beiträge swales these low wetter
areas and we dig holes and see what we
found and wouldn't find anything and so
we moved to the next area dig holes
again and try again and finally we went
to a place with a large wet swale and
when we dug there we found the 2004
deposit well preserved and a layer below
it and as we worked towards the wettest
part of this swale we found more and
more layers and we ended up finding at
least three other layers besides 2004 in
this area here on the island of pratt on
the top level is sam deposited in 2004
carbon dating reveals layers in this
Marsh going back two thousand eight
hundred years and the most recent in
historical times dates from about seven
hundred years ago how do we know that
the sand came from the sea okay at
proton island how do we know it's not a
river flood well the island is of each
Ridge plane there are no rivers there's
no way that a river from the upland can
even get there and so just by context
the only place that the sand could have
come from is the sea
sand layer we found in these deposits in
notch a started off very coarse close to
the ocean and got Finers you go inland
so as the wave comes in is this very
turbulent wave or coming in it slows
down it drops out the heaviest grains
first and it's only left the fine grains
that continue move inland working with
ryan in hea sumatra katrin monica led an
international team which not only found
sand layers matching it as in Thailand
but also found evidence of a slightly
smaller tsunami which hit the country in
1907 but in one place most people
actually survived the wave in 2004 why
do they have the story about the 1907
yeah there's a small island off the
coast of Sumatra called see me Lou
Island and the people there were
strongly affected by an earthquake that
occurred in 1907 and this event wiped
out significant part of the population
was recorded by stories in the memory of
these people the stories of that 1907
tsunami have been passed down through
several generations so when the
earthquake occurred in 2004 they knew
how to react and they actually went to
preordained meeting places there in high
ground for the tsunami arrival only
eight people have a population of almost
90,000 died during the 2004 tsunami so
education is key the Thailand team found
a way to communicate their findings in a
telling way we scrounged up a piece of
corrugated steel roofing from a building
that had been destroyed by the tsunami
and pressed it against the wall of the
pit and cut the thing out and plopped it
on the ground cleaned it up load it on
to the tractor for the two kilometer
bumpy ride back to this
meeting and then laid it out on the
table and showed people okay here's your
record of 2004 you all know about this
because most of them had probably lost
family members to it and then over here
just down below it was sign of an
earlier one 2004 was really a watershed
event because it was so unprecedented at
scale mean almost a quarter of a million
people died during that event really was
a wake-up call for where this could
occur another places probably the
biggest earthquake that can occur would
occur offshore Oregon and Washington in
the Cascadia subduction zone it would
probably be on the order of a magnitude
nine to nine point five earthquake we
were guessing maybe 150 kilometers from
tsunami source for Cascadia tsunami if
it's generated directly off the Strait
of Juan de Fuca maybe 150 kilometres
from there to here as a team Ozil the
coast everywhere everybody along here it
had a ceramic brief really from this
interval you wouldn't be surprised to
see another big Cascadia earthquake
captive tomorrow anything that week as
emergency managers can gain from these
studies to pass on to the folks that
live along the along the beaches here in
the Pacific Northwest it's something
that's concrete and tangible they follow
my signs are going to get to higher
ground
you